how many powers now give is there
there's powers that you have now right
so like I I can I have titles but I can
also bestow titles of nobility you could
you bestow a title of nobility on me it
certainly could could I have one
I mean look Duke or court jester or
court jesters fine yeah guys still where
do you work now well so I I manage tire
shop and you manage a tire shop but then
occasionally you go to the Isle of Man
and you have people beheaded it's not
quite as dramatic as I yeah I mean well
we have a clip of suddenly Royal this is
a clip of one of your visits to the Isle
of Man just let it roll we need to know
anything about this well basically I'm
being challenged by a a Manxman very
proud Manxman Manxman is what you call a
resident to be somebody who is born on
the Isle man from take a look I think
you have to go in over there yeah this
is a unknown for you reckon you're the
king of men do I reckon well your dis
American goddess come over do I not to a
hair I love this well this is this is my
crown right you can't get proclaim
yourself king out of that call me drew
disagree at parties friends
why are you why are you putting up with
that from him you're the king you've
been like remove him he could have been
taken away it's a little bit of a
spoiler but he's not been heard of are
you gonna meet queen elizabeth is that
gonna happen you know our powers I don't
haven't crossed I mean she is a cousin
right but you know she's she's busy
she's kind of on the other side of dying
so you know I don't know stuff like that
did you say I mean she's getting older
you know Saturday that will have a
of course I sort of implied that she
murders people so I don't think you do
this I don't mean any disrespect no no
not at all
just that she murders anyone who
disagrees with her and she hasn't long
to live